WHERE THE MISSILES WERE LAUNCHED
FROM IS STILL UNKNOWN BUT BEGIN
WITH SENIOR FOREIGN AFFAIRS
CORRESPONDENT WHOSE LIVES WITH
THE LATEST ON THE GROUND, GREG.
>> WE HEARD ABOUT A HALF AN HOUR
AGO, ALL QUIET AGAIN HERE IS
RUSSIAN MILITARY MACHINE AND
UKRAINE MILITARY DOES ITS BEST
TO KEEP THEM OFF.
MARIUPOL, HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
REMAIN TRAPPED.
RUSSIAN ARMIES CERAMIC THE CITY
WITH SHELLS AND BOMB STRIKES
WITHOUT WATER, FOOD, ELECTRICITY
FOR MANY DAYS NOW.
RUSSIAN MILITARY SLOWLY AROUND
THE CAPITOL KYIV, IT'S TAKEN IN
THE SUBURB, TROOPS WITHIN 15
MILES, STRUGGLING TO GET OUT OF
IT.
THE CIVILIAN CASUALTIES ARE
RISING AS RUSSIANS SET ASIDE ANY
PRECISE APPROACH, BASICALLY THEY
ARE GOING FOR THE JUGULAR.
HIS THE WESTERN PART OF THE
COUNTRY, A FUNERAL THEY FOR
SOLDIERS FOR THE AIRSTRIKE ON
FRIDAY.
AIRBASES AND MILITARY AID,
CONVOYS, ANGUISH FOR THE LOST
FIGHTERS AND REFUGEES ARE COMING
THROUGH, 2.6 MILLION PEOPL